then Charles Olivera really stole the
show Boy you almost forgot include
myself so many experts so many people in
our field were picking against Charles
Oliveira and it's so weird this guy
never gets the credit that he deserves
because if you look at his resume his
strength of schedule of Fighters that he
beat his his Reign at the the
lightweight division when he was
Champion the names that he beat compared
to khabib it's not even remotely close
strength of schedule khabib's Florida
Atlantic Charles de levers Alabama keep
that same energy when you go to college
football when you look at Alabama who if
they go on to feed or say a Georgia and
the SEC goes on the feed they look at a
team who's even in the Pac-12 or the ACC
they go undefeated nobody goes that's
the best team they blew everybody out
well yeah who are they playing